what good could possibly come from
putting girls in the Boy Scouts
eliminating Boy Scouts what's wrong with
being special the Boy Scouts now are no
longer the Boy Scouts they're going to
be allowing girls to join the Boy Scouts
here's my genuine question of the day
I'd love to hear back from you we were
all asking this in the morning
what is genuinely what's wrong with men
and women being different it tell me I'd
like to see in the comment section what
good could possibly come from putting
girls in the Boy Scouts
eliminating Boy Scouts what's wrong with
being special I I don't understand I
don't understand it when you had Girl
Scouts you had brownies and Boy Scouts
what good can possibly come of this of
course this is everywhere today USA
Today as we enter a new era for our
organization it is important that all
youth can see themselves in Scouting in
every way possible I don't know I don't
know what that means
in every way possible ever seen that say
Girl Scouts Girl Scouts is a good start
the one thing girls should be Boy Scouts
so chief Scout executive Mike Sabo
released an official statement of course
it's been met with praise by the
far-left progressive left and it's been
met with praise by the scouts with the
exception of the newly minted gay
leaders you heard of from last year who
have called to move quote a boner-killer
so they're not thrilled about it so new
merit badges include the gender
inclusivity badge the new friendzone
medallion and many condoms yeah for when
you throw up and you pitch those Congo
tents seriously they just allowed the
gay leaders and they're you know they're
like oh now I got to make a gym brace
with these blocking girl and the Girl
Scout cookie sales by the way have taken
a huge hit losing a lot of sales to the
new co-ed Peep Show
but it's kind of ironic that the left
today and this is the progressive left
they want to remove the original safe
spaces we talk about societal about in
college how we need safe spaces now I
don't need to say space these kinds of
organizations were the original actual
safe space they weren't mandated but
male club's the females had clubs these
were clubs where people could bond
without the opposite sex room because
they felt comfortable right the how many
of them we lost we lost fraternities we
left all we've lost all kinds of
exclusively male clubs and by the way
boy
are incredibly uncomfortable around
young girls there are certain things
that they will do there's certain
information that they will share only in
the presence of other men and male
leaders should I am uncomfortable around
girls Boy Scouts were developed it was
created around this concept that we're
gonna do things little boys like to do
it
yeah just like girls got the different
things that's what they sold brownies
and Boy Scouts my father-in-law join the
Boy Scouts so he could get his masseuse
guys pocketknife he's through in another
Boy Scout was immediately kicked out
should have been it's just to me again
what good can possibly come of this
because we've tried raising young men
for the last several decades the
progressives way look at public schools
it's exclusively designed for for women
okay study after stations that's why
girls do better in grade school than
young boys but then boys do better on
the SATs and you see this discrepancy in
college so we're talking about in
college out there so many men are going
to Sciences and that their men dominate
these these mathematical and science
down science focused fields but guess
what they were they were they were
behind all throughout grade school in
high school because public school is
designed to educate people to wait girls
learn they sit down and listen to
someone speak oh my god
the idea of toxic masculinity
gender-neutral toys right no more male
only spaces they've slowly been eroding
this for a long time we've tried raising
young men the progresses we know hasn't
working but here's another thing that
we're trying to empower women you sees
where the Girl Scouts we're gonna power
the girls by allowing them doing the Boy
Scouts but they had the Girl Scouts
we're trying to empower women by telling
them to be just like men yeah which does
them a great disservice you're teaching
people that they're all interchangeable
you don't you don't empower Charles
Xavier by telling him that he could be
the Hulk
okay just if you don't have that you
don't help women by telling them they
can be just as good as any man in any
area or vice versa this isn't this isn't
about telling young girls that they're
inferior alright it's about being honest
with young girls about being honest with
young boys saying hey listen you're
doing well you know what you're stronger
than your sister I stand with my cousin
you're stronger than your cousin you're
strongest will be careful little Stephen
hey listen you're faster hey listen
you're more physical hey you're gonna be
counted on to protect because you're
more capable of that so we teach young
men where they have certain qualities
unique to their gender which we're not
supposed to do with young girls we
should listen you're more agreeable
which is actually very valuable and many
instances of caring for people and even
in business
listen on average your
or patient you're more capable of
listening you're more articulate you're
better at communicating verbally but
instead we say yeah you can lift the
weights just like the guy and you can go
build a [ __ ] bracelet and take a [ __ ] in
the world well here's a prompt it
doesn't just hurt man it hurts women
right so now we have this this this
syndrome what they call second
adolescents psychologists doctors are
calling it Millennials weren't there
most single generations in decades and
then you have women complaining that men
are less manly than ever yeah that women
hit their 30s now and they're gonna
because men aren't getting married until
they're 27 it's called second adolescent
now I always find this funny when they
go hey you're young you've got plenty of
time to like a 25 year old at one point
you had four kids you might not that
long ago you had nine kids because you
knew four of them would get taken out by
a horse or somebody or a tiger so you're
just playing the odds but now you have
women after second adolescence
complaining that they can't find a man
what the kind of qualities they want but
that's because you not all women but
feminists a feminist societies bred
manliness out of men you scared them off
with your brow beating in your [ __ ]
hats ironically will - will you when you
breed confidence on them in you create
more bullies because you now you just
have a bunch of insecure men running a
ramp it not only what to do themselves
when you create false confidence boss
but it's not earned confident no when
you rip confidence out of men oh yeah
well you rip confidence at him and then
give him false confidence for things
they don't haven't really earned her
that's the problem yeah and you have
that guy in Canada that ran people over
because he couldn't he couldn't relate
with women kind of you know yeah and
that's why then he blames women and
we'll get to that that's reaching too
far the other way so women they want
boys now they want we'll listen let's
let's just everyone's interchangeable
until they're about 30 and then their
biological clock starts ticking like
this and all something went masculine
man I'm just think there used to be a
give-and-take and yet this is I know
sometimes people just talk about the
good old days and folks it well there
are no really there were no good old
days I get it some things needed to be
improved but there used to be a mutual
appreciation with the complementarianism
a minimum and that's what we had boy
scouts out so we had Girl Scouts and
people didn't need to start a march okay
men and women didn't own different roles
because they hate each other because
they loved each other right a man said
all right I've been Bert this is one
thing to by the way women out there I
hope you understand this when women say
you don't know pain you don't know what
being a mother is the hardest job in the
world you don't know pain you don't give
birth let me give you a little bit of
context because we get a lot of emails
from young men men as soon
they are old enough to understand the
concept of being a man
don't burn with the pressure of
providing for their family for the rest
of life so they know it they know it's
expected them sure women can work if
they want to but it's not expected of
you that is the kind of compression that
is unique to the male biology now it
doesn't mean that women do not have
compressions do not have stressors that
are unique to women back in the day men
didn't go out and earn for the family
and come because they hated their lives
they didn't go down to the coal mines
and get the black lung because I wanted
to come home and tell their wife about
what a horrible person she was a woman
didn't change all kinds of diapers and
didn't cook meals for her family because
she hated her husband they did it
because they understood that they loved
each other and in order to make it work
we need to complement each other with
our gender roles and our biological
advantages and disability now of course
yep listen some men develop PTSD beat
the hell out of their kids they came
home after a couple world worse or daven
with a glass rod I get it we own we own
if we own that house but feminists harm
young men when they tell men you don't
know what it's like to give birth no
when they tell them that you don't you
have no possible they create a toxic
environment I talked about this with the
recent election how [ __ ] when Hillary
Clinton was running out would become the
new n-word remember yeah we talked about
them I air we got so much flak including
from conservatives now why did I say
that because under Obama race relations
were at their worst in our lifetime fact
Wow now you can't really observe it
right now but that's the Hillary Clinton
syndrome remember that night whenever
one went from being racist who didn't
support Barack Obama to being sexist
because I didn't support Hillary Eagle
transformation haven't you felt that
shift it was racism racism racism and
then all of a sudden Donald Trump's
president and it's [ __ ] hat and it's
just it's all it is is gender war in
your face I can guarantee you gender
relations are at their worst in 2016
here's an example we just talked about
this the recent Reuters polls young
white men favored Democrats in 2016 48
to 36 now that swapped 46 to 37 that
doesn't happen you see the pendulum
swinging hard the other way and they
have a lot of men who don't believe in
any of the hashtag me to campaign member
when we started we were going this is
terrible I can't believe it our burned
alive the guys were sexually assaulted
yeah but then every woman and then every
woman came forward and guys gonna hold
on a second I have to look at this a
little bit leery now because feminists
have told us that we have to believe
that
everything and that none of these women
should be held accountable this is what
is also important want to leave it on
this note unless anyone else has
anything to add there men need to hold
other men accountable yes of course you
can't see can't just pull the
conservative version of John short so
this is I do think this is corrosive to
society the Boy Scouts issue right now I
think all of it it's all it's all us
again what good can come of it spend
computer was talking about this earlier
it really is about just entirely
eliminating gender lines right again
which is a big irony why do you need
diversity at that point um but I don't
want to be the john oliver who just
[ __ ] about the things that I do think
our problem I think all of us are agree
our problem men can you can do things I
need to hold other men accountable I see
men's rights activist who just [ __ ]
about the browbeating yeah now here's
the thing we can't believe that men have
certain roles and then that own the
responsibilities that come with them and
just [ __ ] about feminism right I
encourage men out there you want to
start fixing this and we've seen this
with Jordan Pederson with GAD said we've
seen a change with young people open to
new ideas your goal isn't just to
convert them it's not your job to change
their mind but you can plant the seed so
if you're a man out there guess what I
encourage you men out there to treat
women well yes alimony is unfair if you
look at the majority of states and a
woman can take half and leave you in
screw it is absolutely terrible but the
way to fix it is on a micro level as a
man be a gentleman and encourage
masculine for gonna talk about toxic
masculinity and [ __ ] about it and [ __ ]
about what feminists do that's kind of
the syndrome we had with the Donald
Trump thing where people just came out
and said I hate liberal this
I hate leftists that well I do too but
do you ever offer solutions we see that
from the left with John Oliver he just
[ __ ] and never ever offers a solution
it starts with you encourage men to
treat women well to treat them like
women to acknowledge the biological
differences that make all of the
wondrous splendor that is lady because
you love them show them that you love
them and women show men that you love
them and it's okay to recognize your
differences then we'll start making some
progress if you like this video
subscribe hit the notification bell or
if you want to continue to enjoy free
content support us a lot with credit com
/mo Club where you get the full nightly
show an hour every day free along with
all of our friends content if not you
don't wanna do any of those things
you're probably just here you're
watching me seething you came here
to hate watch that being said the
internet was created for people like you